[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week where you vote you decide who
is the bone end of the week we break it
down gabe are you ready for this bone in
because we got a few of them let's let's
bring them up here we got senator chuck
grassley
ron desantis of florida that fascist and
who is this one on the end who is this
clown this is the joker without makeup
oh
she's the one who beat who beat darth
vader junior in in wyoming harriet
hegman
hagman is that jack hagman
hagman well
i would think it would be two g's now i
don't know names are pronounced so i
think you got it spelled wrong there i
mean no it's alien
no i think it well if that's the case no
i'm saying i'm saying just like salsa
tony texted me a message last night of
him eating chips and and uh in salsa
salsa salsa salsa i'm from missouri
we even even in the chant for the
missouri tigers it's m-i-z-z-o-u
and there's a z in missouri apparently
it's missouri
yeah yeah
that doesn't translate over to spanish
why i mean salsa that's how we say it
here you eat chips chips
chips
senator chuck
grassley
okay well who should we start with
should we start with this harriet hagman
yeah let's let's get her out of here we
go should we go with her is that who we
should go with first i mean what what i
mean other than she is
absolutely crazy
i mean and other other than other than
the doppelganger of carrie lake show a
video here of um
of harriet hegman um here she is on a
trafficking video i don't know here's
here she is on the parents appears to be
sean hannity show let's listen to that
congratulated you and wished you well
how did the call go
well there wasn't a phone call while i
does she look like she can blink it
looks like it's a struggle for her to
blink every i just want to say this
every time i see an interview with her
she's always like this
boom his eyes are wide open and i never
i never see her blink how much she's
always like
holy [ __ ] she is alert she is alert
folks
whoosh energy drinks coffee no this
person is probably gonna be a member of
congress isn't that disheartening that
we're gonna have we're gonna have lauren
bobert marjorie taylor green possibly
this [ __ ] and the the queen of morons
sarah palin possibly in the congress i'm
going to meet a [ __ ] caucus let's
listen i was going in and getting ready
to do my acceptance speech last night
and had just arrived at the watch party
she called and left a very brief
two-second message on mice on myself why
did she say what'd she say [ __ ] off is
that within like two seconds i mean
yeah but here's the thing [ __ ] off liz
cheney knew
she knew
that harriet hagman would do this so
then she released
the actual voicemail audio
to say
i know i know what you're going to do i
know what you're going to say
here's the actual voicemail yeah this is
the audio okay so here here's the audio
let's play this here
he's calling it so we should go
all right here is liz genie calling it's
about 8 13 on tuesday the 16th i'm
calling to concede the election uh and
uh to uh to congratulate you on the win
thanks bye-bye
longer than two seconds longer than and
also also
the respect though i don't believe
harriet hagman deserves it
but the respect of following through and
saying i lost the election i will call
and concede and say congratulations well
and you know um
when an election is actually counted and
and it's valid and it's safe secure
it is uh it is appropriate for
regardless whether you're a politician
even more secure than the last election
because of all these accusations so
they're like well i guess we gotta like
make sure that this [ __ ] isn't actually
broken i mean because liz cheney can say
stop the steal it's rigged it's rigged i
didn't i didn't i didn't lose i won and
be continuing this until now until 2030
to talk about how she won this election
even though there's three elections in
the meantime
okay well so it's pretty clear why she
ended up on bonehead of the week i mean
she also spreads a lot of lies around
biden she believes that biden she wanted
to you know did she say he's a human
trafficker or something yeah there was
uh let me see if i can find that video
this is coming from the person who
supports greg abbott who is who is
actually bussing human beings
trafficking them literally across the
united states because he doesn't like
the color of their skin
or the or the place they're from he's
trafficking them across the united
states jesus [ __ ] christ so i guess
that's why this bonehead ends up on bone
another way why do we have chuck
grassley on here what's that what's the
deal with that guy that what's that
is uh oh do you want to play the video
of her saying oh yeah real quick you got
it it's three seconds you're talking
about you're talking about hagman yeah
hagman hagman okay let's let's play the
video in the back of hagman um
saying some really weird nonsense i mean
it isn't surprising is she saying that
she's saying it on steve bannon's trader
tv i mean that's where this is right
yeah
this is it okay let's listen
joe biden is the largest or the most
destructive human trafficker in our
history i mean they absolutely project
here here's more projection yeah their
party is literally trafficking
people out of texas because they don't
like where they're from they don't like
the color their skin they don't like
their [ __ ] names and they're
trafficking human beings literally
busting them through traffic on highways
across the country and there's dropping
them off on the side right but even more
so it's they're not telling them where
they're taking them right you know if
you're getting on the bus and you go
into texas let's say and then you're
like oh greg abbott he's deporting them
he's taking them back to you know well i
guess i don't know where they originated
from it could have been mexico could
have been guatemala could have been
somewhere else but the idea that they're
like all right we're just gonna
send him down to mexico we're gonna
deport him but that's not what they tell
them they either tell them a lie or they
don't tell them where they're sending
them at all which again if you didn't
want a certain group of people in the
country
which is like very unchristian of you in
terms of accepting those people and
sheltering them and caring for them and
giving them the support they need
instead of doing that you say
you don't belong here
and instead of then sending them outside
of the country because the whole problem
was them coming into the country they
then bust them to another part of the
country
so they're not trying they're not trying
to solve a problem they're trying to
make this the problem bigger for
democrats but democrats are accepting
and saying great we will help well but
they're actually they're actually
helping
the economy by sending these people to
places where they need people to do jobs
to labor i mean we need labor in some of
these places the reason why you're so
frustrated when you go to places
sometimes and and they they either don't
have enough help or they don't have
enough people to to do the service that
you want as quickly as you want is
because they know i'm the labor so it's
sending these these buses of people who
absolutely are willing to work and want
to be part of america want to be part of
our economy and sending them to places
where we need this labor like that's
actually one of the reasons why our
economy is it has is having such trouble
is because for [ __ ] five years
five years they struggled to get the
labor in this country we they absolutely
did not want anyone who wanted to come
here to be a part of the american
economy who wanted to give labor because
of the color their skin or where they're
from or their name and the fact that
they're like oh well you know us as
republicans we want to keep this country
white because that's what they want to
do they want it white because white is
right according to republicans but
here's the problem with their logic by
allowing more people who aren't white
into this country
they're creating a more diverse
and eclectic country the real goal of
what america was right this american
dream this melting pot of cultures and
people and languages and in skin colors
that's what america should be and that's
what america strives to be but
republicans say no it's got to be white
because that's right and then they're
[ __ ] over their own plan by allowing
more people who aren't white into the
country
so
they they [ __ ] up every time right well
they're always there they're always
overplaying their hand speaking of
crusty white dudes that overplay their
hand here's chuck grassley um and
apparently the reason why he's on bone
of the week is he overplayed his hand
here he is in a
town hall a town hall style meeting um
if you notice there's a common
denominator here in this meeting but
let's listen to what chuck grassley
tells these folks in this meeting
probably hundreds of thousands of iowans
we're struggling to pay their insulin
why can't we do something about that so
this uh this voter here in iowa is
asking uh
uh uh
general krusty here i i think he's
probably he's probably the last living
remnant of the civil war is it wasn't
truck isn't chuck grassley old enough to
uh actually
chuck grassley his his uh his whole
security number is one oh okay he's gay
he was the very first one what that
means he's the first one
he came out they came out and he was
like we should probably figure out some
sort of numbering since people well
let's let's let's see what chuck
grassley's responses to his constituent
who is worried about affording insulin
let's see what he says because i think
this might be important there might be
an important vote coming up uh after
this clip was taken let's listen for the
35 dollar cab
and
senator shaheen
from new hampshire
senator collins
from uh
maine are working on bipartisan jail to
do that
oh well it would be nice if we could get
senators like chuck grass he voted
against it right so if we're here who i
know i know the audio was low because a
couple people asked the question the
audit was low but basically the guy was
asking about
um the cash on insulin right right and
he's 35 will i support capping 30 not
only that not only that he brings up a a
piece of legislation that his republican
colleagues are working on to try to make
this accomplished exactly and he tells
his constituents
he says
well he said he would do it and he
didn't do it he didn't do it he voted
against it
right so uh anyone in iowa anyone in
iowa who has family members who are are
not even on insulin who want to make
sure that you you again engage in your
ballot and engage in your democracy tell
all your family and friends especially
your [ __ ] republican uncle earl yeah
that chuck grassy is a [ __ ] liar he's
a [ __ ] liar and he will continue to
lie to you and he's not just lying to
you about the thirty five dollars in
right yeah like that's the little lie
he's okay with that little lie there's a
lot of big lies that he's telling you to
do so [ __ ] chuck grassley um i'm i'm i'm
not surprised that he ended up on this
list now we have um an alpha cuck and a
dishonorable mention what should i do
first you want to do the alpha cuck
first you want to yeah let's do the
alpha cook okay here's the alpha cuck
for the week allen why sober wait i this
name sounds familiar ellen eiselberg is
this the same allen weissenberger is
completely [ __ ] in new york mm-hmm
yeah you know just to clear it up yes he
may look like grumpy cat okay let's go
back but
he he does he's totally ashamed he looks
like you know the you didn't edit this
in any way to make it i didn't look like
i didn't do anything i just took a photo
or rather i took a photo that was on the
internet and i just cropped out his face
that's all i did it looks like he's
trying to it looks like he's trying to
smell his lip or something
well keep in mind this is a photo now
the original photo is him in focus and
trump in
in the front he's behind him oh this is
the famous this is the famous where he's
standing behind trump because he was he
was basically second in charge yeah at
the trump org and that's the real story
here and i've been saying this for
months and months and months ever since
he was indicted that yeah it's not just
him indicted it's it's the trump crime
organization right the trump crime
organization is also indicted on
criminal charges now the most
significant part of this because a lot
of people don't feel like he got enough
time but i don't know if anyone knows
about rikers or not yeah but two days in
rikers probably seems like 100 years but
he's supposed to go to rikers for five
months that's what the judge has
sentenced but we'll probably only do
three right correct because he'll get
because it's a state charge he'll get
parole uh he'll have a parole officer
yeah that's assuming that's assuming
that rikers and the stress of rikers
doesn't actually get right because
they're kind of overloaded right right
right yeah so that well i mean i was
going to say like just the stress of
going to rikers like the health oh of
himself because he is an old dude yeah
he's he's really grumpy he's really
grumpy yeah he's grumpy cat like that
doesn't do anything
here's the picture yeah look at that the
grumpy cat right there i'm telling you
but going to riker is one it's you know
one of the most infamous
prisons there are in the united states
it's [ __ ] gross it is definitely a
place no human being wants to be right
sure not even the people who work there
want to be there yeah so the fact that
he'll be there potentially from three to
five months before he has his next
appearance
right well and the other thing that the
judge made sure to tell alan weiselberg
is that he basically told them you
better tell the truth all right um
i'm giving you the max which i think is
17 years right right so so alan
weisselberg even though he seems like
he's out of the woods with his
five-month sentence of writers he is not
out of the woods here because he has to
actually he actually has to help the
state in the charges against the trump
crime organization which
i would imagine could turn into federal
charges pretty damn quickly um when the
evidence starts to be uncovered from the
chief financial officer the number two
in charge of the tax fraud organization
the the russian money laundering machine
that is the trump crime organization so
i think i think i think he
he is a great alpha cuck this week
because he's definitely going to cuck
in rikers yeah yeah well also i mean the
main reason i put him on the list here
for was because of the fact like
he was willing to testify against i mean
because he was forced to willing to
testify against the trump org right cut
a deal but was still unwilling to do
that for trump
so he was unwilling to actually comment
and put any sort of disparaging or
uh you know crucial information to make
a case against trump now i'm sure they
obviously already have a case against
him and they're building stuff
um but
well this tax fraud this tax fraud this
tax scheme that they had didn't just
because there's a civil case against the
trump organization the trump crime
family um for the state of new york as
well not just this criminal case there's
a civil case where they're going to try
to cut this the trump organization down
like a fresh-cut tree and i would
imagine tish james right now is
sharpening her acts like abraham lincoln
yeah you know and and i i would imagine
i would imagine that tits james is going
to aim and cut it down uh very
appropriately now the question is rather
the feds probably get a hold of what
these crimes that allen weisselberg are
going to expose um and and rather
there's cooperation between the
manhattan da's office and the southern
district of new york in these in this
tax fraud scheme that probably wasn't
just for the state of new york but it
was also for our government and that's
why he never wanted us to see his tax
returns because there was crime in them
and i'm sure that's exactly what the
manhattan da's gonna have evidence of to
charge the trump organization with crime
which means the feds can probably step
in at some point we'll see we'll see if
there's a federal case to be made in new
york we definitely know there's one uh
in florida now and there's one in dc
possibly one in georgia as well so he's
he's facing four federal districts that
possibly will bring cases speaking of
georgia
speaking of georgia we have a
dishonorable mention yeah this person
hails
from georgia yep and i i don't know
maybe maybe she um maybe she lost her
extra toe that people are supposed to
have in georgia marjory hoof foot green
is our dishonorable mention why is she
our dishonorable mention today game what
what what is that
she introduced a bill to make gender
affirming care for transgender big
surprise felony yeah right that was my
big surprise
she tweeted out the photo of her at
bedminster with trump and tucker carlson
she's like i got a big announcement to
make on tucker carlson tonight and
everyone's like oh is she gonna say that
she's gonna be his running mate in 2024
is she gonna
uh talk about another affair she had
with someone that wasn't a tantric sex
guru or wasn't the uh crossfit manager
or is she going to you know maybe she
reveals hey i've got an extra toe
surgery that's coming up to replace the
missing one that i have i don't know but
basically the measure would make it that
it's a class c felony which is
punishable up to 25 years in prison for
doctors or anyone else who provides
gender affirming health care to a minor
that she even wants to include adults
doesn't she yeah this is this is the
boneheaded tweet here um
she acts like she's not on twitter but
she's definitely on twitter she's like
oh they banned me i'm censored no you're
not a [ __ ] account that you tweet
from all the time she tweeted here
tonight
i'll be joining tucker carlson for a big
announcement tune in to fox news at 8 pm
here's the picture that she posted um of
her like i love when he puts that stubby
finger in my face that little stubby
finger it's so gross look at this little
hands
look at look at look at oh god
look at this he does have tiny hands
doesn't he
i mean even tucker carlson marjorie
taylor green has bigger hands than he
does yeah yeah no it's uh maybe we
should get some kind of measurement on
this picture or something to to to uh to
convince this was the last time people
saw tucker crosston
is it really
well i mean you got to imagine like what
happened after this right you he oh yeah
yeah yeah he had this golf tournament
and then the search warrant happens and
then tucker carlson was not going for
like a week poof he was gone people
started subbing in for him and
the other guy that
tried to be tucker like these are all
people that
uh had to had to replace him because he
was gone on vacation i don't know you
know it's really it's really [ __ ]
gross here is the um
here's the clip i think of her announced
giving her a big announcement that um
she's gonna sleep with donald trump i
mean um try to
be a bigot right out in the open
like she is let's listen
let me tell you something yeah this is a
referendum on the republican party
when we take back the majority if the
american people elect us we need we have
a lot of work to do not only do we need
to impeach merit garland we need to
clean out the corrupt fbi we need to
hold the democrats accountable and
defund all of their climate garbage 87
claimant garbage
forget the climate [ __ ] the climate the
climate can go to hell i mean maybe we
could shoot it down with lasers and just
like i guess
i mean you know their bigotry is working
for him i guess maybe maybe not worrying
about the climate actually being
anti-climate will help let's listen 1000
irs army but there's one thing that we
have got to do and we're not even a
party worth deserving of the american
people's votes if we cannot protect
children from this horrific child abuse
and create this to be a felony because
this practice has to end it's the case
it's the kind of things nightmares are
made of and these are monsters under
kids beds that are doing these horrific
things to them
literally literally her party in
tennessee is the one that want to marry
children yeah this is the she she said
one truth in there she said we do not
deserve the vote of the american people
right
that part i would say is absolutely 100
true because people like marjory taylor
green people like tucker carlson people
like
ted cruz
all of these people
will stab constituents in the back but
not only that
they want to be the people that go into
your home
pull up pull down your pants pull up
your skirt whatever right well yeah they
definitely are obsessed with your
genitalia they love
they love to look at those things they
love to make sure is that really what
you are
those are the things that will
catastrophically
traumatize someone
and make them know or make them think
about
the boogeyman or the monster under the
bed like she says they're the party that
will make anyone and everyone afraid
of what will happen if they take control
which is we want to make sure that you
are
who you say you are right what gender
are you
well
speaking speaking of speaking of bigots
i want to move to because we're we're
getting low on time here and i want to
make sure we give the winner plenty of
time uh we know the winner is governor
ron desantis that [ __ ]
that nazi that let's go brandon nazi
down in florida he's really working on a
fascist state but gabe there's some
breaking news here just in the last few
hours a judge has declared ron desantis
back florida law that restricts
race-based conversation and analysis in
business and
education unconstitutional
uh the tallahassee u.s district mark
walker said the stop woke act violates
the first amendment and is in its
it's [ __ ] it's absolute [ __ ] and garbage
here's the thing
the the stop woke act
is stopping from people from expressing
and practicing their first amendment
right
well
again the chelsea handler clip that i
played from earlier
the bone ends don't even they skip right
over this first amendment yeah the only
thing they get from first amendment is i
get to say whatever i want without
consequences which is not what it says
and then the second one the likes two
second amendment lets me have guns and
kill whoever i want to kill especially
my enemies who who want to give me
consequences for my speech on the first
one and again they don't understand
these amendments they don't on they just
don't get that you can say whatever dumb
[ __ ] [ __ ] you want to say but it's
just the reason why is this the reason
why he was on bone out of the week or
did we have well it's not just one the
original reason was because of his
attack towards teachers right he was
attacking teachers this week to say like
uh you know most people
you know well one he was he was going
after um
well he went he went after book fairs
then he went after um teachers and
uh
um
uh and tenure which is a debatable topic
but he went after that and then he also
was like look if you're a veteran who
has 60 credits or more of from from a
college
oh yes i remember that and teach our
classes right but then he also was like
oh you know these people you know get
their education and i don't really like
the argument that he made was basically
people who go to school to learn
teaching type stuff i forget how we
phrased it but it was something dumb
like that like he said um
who who go to study like teaching or the
practice of teaching or whatever the
[ __ ] it was
he
says oh you know because i don't really
believe in that stuff right like you can
go to that and you can practice it but i
don't really think it works right that's
what his argument was saying right
people go to school to become an
educator to learn practices and
protocols and how you know you know how
they should go about teaching a class of
anywhere from uh young children to
adults right and he basically saying
like ah yeah
you could you don't have to go to
college for that you don't have to get a
master's in that you don't have to get a
phd whatever it is depending on the the
level that you want to teach at
that is what he was arguing and that was
my biggest complaint this week was the
fact that he was attacking teachers and
saying you actually don't need to go to
any sort of training as long as you took
some college credits
that's good enough for me well the other
thing that's like keep everyone [ __ ]
done the other reason i believe is
because he announced that he was going
to arrest some people who voted
illegally
and you know he's he's throwing out all
these things that there's big election
fraud and i think there's like three
people that they're gonna arrest for
election run but he failed he failed to
do the same thing when those boneheads
at the villages he failed to have the
big huge pressure silent when the trump
supporters voted three and four times at
the villages the the highest
concentration of voter fraud in the
entire country in florida at the
villages for in the name of donald trump
so he failed to recognize that so ron
desantis of course appropriately is the
winner here you decided that ron
desantis was the winner i almost believe
that i think ron desantis would possibly
win even if donald trump was on this
thing what do you think it's possible i
mean like look if he's such a [ __ ]
bonehead yeah you know we could see we
could see we could take it as a
more of a metric to see like who would
perform well in a 2024 presidential poll
hey we should do a poll we should do a
2024 bonus as soon as this election's
over yeah i don't want to get ahead of
ourselves this is the most important
election so as soon as this election's
over i tell you that the most important
election is going to be the next one as
soon as this one's over so let's
consider that around those holidays to
really put out a poll to see who is
going to be the bonehead of 2024 i like
that idea but let's let's do this
let's not waste much time let's give ron
desantis the fascist let's go brandon
nazi down in florida
dumming america down dumbing them down
banning math banning book fairs
bone end of the week ron desantis
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ron desantis bone end of the week well
deserved i don't know this is probably
the third or fourth time he's been the
bone of the week this guy could
be on the list again we could have like
15 people on the list consistently yeah
and they would i mean if i really wanted
to i could go back every week to see who
actually yeah well yeah and i could have
and then i could have like record
setters and stuff you know do you do
some uh
yeah
here's here's the thing about um this
bonehead because i i forgot to show a
clip earlier in the show of someone
running for governor who actually uh
could be a governor who could be a real
governor for the people and not only is
he showing a way
to be a governor and to get out there
and talk to his community you know we've
been talking a lot about community gabe
here on the tony michael's podcast but
um i want to show you there was a bunch
of boneheads speaking of bonehead of the
week that showed up in support of greg
abbott at a beto aurora community
meeting where he was talking to real
people real community members no telling
where these people came these boneheads
came from
watch
watch how beto aurora
deals with greg abbott boneheads this is
[ __ ] fantastic
and listen um lest we be
annoyed or judge these avid people
let's have a little bit of sympathy
their candidate never shows up to talk
to them
[Applause]
oh
i love this guy i [ __ ] love this guy
if you guys missed it what better what's
happening here is uh inside the
community hall here where he's talking
to his constituents who are going to
vote for him to be an actual governor of
the state of texas um and he's trying to
work through their issues and tell them
about their issues and hear what they're
saying listening to them having
conversations with them even even
turning trump supporters to be better
voters signing hats signing hats
trump hats maga hats it's
incredible to watch it's incredible to
see this happening in front of our eyes
but the abbott supporters are standing
outside chanting and yelling right yeah
so they're trying they're trying to stop
him from talking
so they're yelling and screaming and
then what he points out very uh
he just dunks on him just i mean you
remember the game nba jam and then oh
yeah the sega game
he's on fire
just [ __ ] dunks on him he says from
downtown
he says you got to feel sorry for these
folks outside yelling and screaming
their actual candidate won't come and
actually talk to them yeah um which is
what's even worse is their candidate
won't even show up to the funeral right
for the victims from the uvalde school
shooting
that's how much of a [ __ ] [ __ ] bag
greg abbott is he won't even show up he
has no empathy no
sense of remorse or sadness or any
ability to relate to his constituents
that he will show up to one of the worst
massacres that they've had in in recent
history
right i mean there's el paso as well
but the guy doesn't show up the only
time he ever has a conference is when
the nra's involved or wow other people
who are trying to gaslight victims well
when he's trying to women's when he's
trying to take women's rights away when
he's trying to make sure that teenagers
are forced to have
babies all kinds of great stuff that
greg abbott's doing or not doing for his
constituents and beto so strategically
with a knife in front of his crowd and
you notice how the crowd responds
because they know exactly what beto was
talking about the people in this room
have felt abandoned abandoned by their
fascist governor greg abbott and beto is
not abandoning them he's there with them
he's talking to him he's listening to
them and that's the most important thing
about community and the most important
thing about our democracy
so make sure you do the thing in
democracy engage in your ballot but the
other place you can vote is on twitter
at tony michael's pod for bone head of
the week every single week gabe we do it
every week
the second hour of the show bone end of
the week every friday
the other thing we do gabe is we
actually put it up on all the podcast
directories so you can download apple
spotify google on sunday subscribe to
the youtube channel so you don't miss
bonehead of the week a replay on sunday
sunday sunday sunday so subscribe to the
youtube channel right here
at the tony michaels podcast do not mess
a single s episode of the tony michaels
podcast or bonehead of the week
congratulations to ron desantis for
winning again bone end of the week this
week
stick around stick around bonang might
be over but we have a few announcements
right after this
[Music]
[Applause]